Josiah difficult tournament for you but
with a nice touch to finish it good
victory with the white pieces sum up
your experience here at the Juniors
yeah I mean getting the wild card and
this is my last event as well I really
wanted to uh to do well but I just I
feel like I never really got on the
right foot and especially after the rest
of it I just I lost three in a row and I
feel like maybe I just relax a bit too
much after the rest day and I just kind
of lost my focus but I mean overall I'm
you know happy to be here and obviously
ending with a win was pretty good going
into my next important tournament World
Cup so I'm pretty happy to finish off on
a good note so we're actually going with
Carissa as well and some other players
from the United States the World Cup
what are your Ambitions for that event
it's a big one
um well obviously every game I play I'll
be the underdog and so you know I'm just
trying to go there and play good chess
honestly like going into every event uh
moving forward I just want to play good
chess and especially after this
tournament like I just I really did not
so
um you know I have Ambitions but at the
same time I just want to take it a game
at a time and see where that leads me
absolutely and I see you're sporting a
very nice jacket today that's uh the
Mizu chess jacket you should have
sported that a few more rounds maybe you
would have gotten some more victories
the two games that I won I was wearing
this jacket and actually
um at the Continental where I qualify
for the World Cup I wore this jacket
every single day there you go guys any
questions for uh lucky jacket yeah so
why are you not wearing the jacket
well actually I wore the jacket every
single game I played after continental
and I was like
undefeated for like 20 games wow and
then I lost the game it was actually
against Brandon at National open I was
like okay I'll retire the jacket for now
but I think I should have brought it
back
oh I have a question
um not Brandon but uh Josiah we played
Duchess during the during the rest day
the 15 you know Club anniversary and I
was extremely surprised you are such a
strong Duchess player how long you've
been playing
that was actually only my only like my
third duck chess game like ever
so I don't know maybe I just had some
intuition for duck chest yeah I
certainly didn't carry over into the
real games
A Gifted duck Chester definitely there
is a talent there absolutely
well congratulations on finishing this
tournament strongly and good luck at the
World Cup Championship
good luck uh for the knock